in this video we're going to talk about
iodine I'm going to really increase your
awareness on this vitally important
trace mineral now trace minerals are
those minerals needed in very small
amounts but the problem is there's no
RTA's or requirements yet for trace
minerals only for the bigger minerals
like calcium and vitamins and things
like that but trace trace minerals are
those minerals needed in very very tiny
amounts usually micrograms not
milligrams okay but iodine is definitely
needed because the function of iodine
supports the brain function in a growing
infant without enough iodine that child
could be mentally [ __ ] all cells
need iodine so not just the thyroid the
reproductive organs need iodine
including the breast the uterus the
ovaries the prostate the testicles we'll
get more into that in the next section
but the point is that if a female has
very large breasts they need more iodine
to support those breasts okay
iodine is also used to help detoxify
heavy metals so if you have if you're
consuming a lot of shellfish and you're
getting mercury and things if you have
enough iodine on your system that will
protect the detail will help you
detoxify it iodine is needed to reduce
the need for insulin so it's involved in
diabetes or slowing down diabetes it's
involved in stabilizing blood sugars and
you know I'm just kind of showing you
some other things that people can do if
they're diabetic and they consume some
iodine it could take a big stress off
the whole mechanism with blood sugars
and of course the one of the most
important things for iodine is the
control of metabolism through the
thyroid so if there's not enough iodine
your metabolism could be shut down by at
least fifty percent or more
and then you gain weight okay so if
you've ever talked about the thyroid in
relationship to like thyroxine or t4 or
t3 and what that means is that the
number associated with that T like
thyroid t3 or four that's the num
of iodine molecules that are attached to
that thyroid hormone okay so that's what
that means and so when the thyroid sends
out a hormone and it sends out t4 that's
the one that it starts with but it's
inactive and even when people take
medication like synthroid for example
that's t4 and what happens is that that
is made active or activated by the liver
and the kidney so in other words eight
eighty percent of t4
is converted through the liver through
the gallbladder through the bile ducts
and 20% of the t4 is converted through
the kidneys so one cause of thyroid
problems or iodine problems would be the
lack of the conversion because the gall
bladders not there or there's a problem
the gall bladder the livers damaged or
there's kidney damage or many other
reasons too
one side note is that you need the other
trace mineral inium to convert t4 to t3
and that's why it's always important
when you're taking an iodine to take it
in a concentrate of a blend of all the
trace minerals not just one you have to
really look at a holistic approach with
that so so we have that now let's talk
about just the causes of iodine
deficiencies there's direct causes and
indirect causes and the reason I'm
showing this is because I want to expand
your awareness on all the possibilities
so we don't have tunnel vision and you
don't go to the doctor and he says oh
yeah we checked your thyroid it's normal
but they're not looking at their liver
the kidney the iodine in your diet all
these factors all right so first first
thing is it could be just low iodine it
could come from the diet why because the
soils really don't have any more iodine
in it especially unless you live about a
hundred miles from the ocean there's
really no more iodine in the soils so
you're the farmers don't necessarily
replace that they replace it with maybe
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium but
not all the trace minerals so you're
consuming food without iodine that could
be
why you're not getting the iodine the
normal requirement that our body needs
is a hundred and fifty micrograms
so it's a very small amount and that is
set up I think by some standards that
were a bit too low because in the in
Japan they're they consume a hundred
times more iodine than Americans and
they have a lot less thyroid problems
breast cancer cyst on the breast and
ovarian problems unless prostate
problems then Americans so I think
there's definitely a connection with
that but it could be also the person is
maybe eating a bit too much cruciferous
but honestly you would have to consume a
lot of cruciferous to create an iodine
deficiency so not just a couch like a
day but if you are consuming a lot of
cruciferous I highly recommend that you
add a source of iodine to your diet I'll
get into that in a little bit because
that cruciferous does have a tendency to
deplete or block some small amounts of
iodine okay so we have that and then we
have low salt diet so if someone's on a
low salt diet and they're not having any
salt likes even sea salt
then where they get near iodine they're
not even doing iodized salt so that
could be one possible reason we just
want to look at every possible reason
stress stress can also deplete iodine in
the minerals and then a thing called
endocrine disrupters that would be
something like an exposure to pesticides
insecticides herbicides fungicides right
from the food or from the environment
that can also mess with your thyroid and
block the absorption of iodine because
these endocrine disruptors these
chemicals do compete for the receptors
for iodine so let's say we have the
receptor right here and iodine is
supposed to go in there like that
well what happens is the endocrine
disrupters will block it so they won't
let that iodine connect in there and
that could be some of the heavy metals
like mercury and it could be other
elements like
fluoride chloride and even the sink
called bromide
alright bromide is a very interesting
element because in the 70s we used to
have iodine in all the flour products
the bakery products okay but then they
switched it with bromide I don't know
why they did that so in the past people
were getting iodide and then in the 70s
we had a bromine without the iodine and
guess what that alone can decrease your
absorption of iodine by having too much
bromine in your breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes of
course you're not doing that if you're
watching my blog anyway so you don't you
have nothing to worry about okay so we
have those things that can interfere
just directly low iodine from that
now there's other other reasons why you
could also have a low iodine number one
high levels of estrogen can block your
iodine all right it can also increase
the need for more iodine interesting so
that could explain why when you get
pregnant the spike of estrogen you end
up with a thyroid problem yeah because
of the spike of estrogen severely blocks
the iodine absorption into the Vaught
thyroid so what are all the sources of
increased estrogen number one getting
pregnant to hormonal placement therapy
three birth control pills eating foods
without that are not hormone free could
do it there's certain milks and meats
that have hormones and then having too
much soy soy is estrogenic especially if
it's not fermented okay the Japanese
always have fermented soy I like tofu
tempeh tempeh miso soup they don't
consume the soy protein isolates in the
prepackaged diet foods that that are out
there the veggie patties that
vegetarians consume with it all soy base
a lot of the protein powders um it's in
the baby food
you name it having a fibroid which by
the way is caused by high estrogen can
also deplete the iodine in the body and
obstruct the thyroid and then having a
very heavy or regular or painful cycle
which is estrogen dominance can also
lower your iodine okay
and then lastly we talked about this
briefly before a liver damage so if you
have liver damage it could be that could
be the source of your your low iodine or
your lack of conversion into the thyroid
or a lack of bile now I've done videos
and bile and biles the detergent to
helps break down the grease and without
enough bio you won't have that iodine
conversion and that can mess up the
thyroid or I'll not allow you to convert
the active form of the thyroid hormone
to make it work so it's always inactive
so it really doesn't work so you get a
blood test that doesn't mean anything
they're not looking at all the other
possible causes of a thyroid problem and
so what causes low bile is sometimes
when you become a vegetarian you have no
saturated fats well saturated fats some
such artifacts stimulate the bio
released without saturated fats you
can't your your gallbladder kind of
shrivels up and you don't produce enough
file anymore
that could be one cause and then stress
high levels of the stress hormone from
the adrenal called cortisol that one
that makes the belly fat that can also
block your bio therefore decreasing your
iodine so those are all the possible
causes and then the next part I'm going
to show you all the symptoms of iodine
deficiency so let's talk about these
symptoms of iodine deficiency number one
you get fat you gain weight all over
that would be a thyroid body type why
because all the cells are controlled by
the thyroid and iodine so all the cells
get fat on them it affects the cognitive
it makes you feel very very sluggish and
brain fog especially in the morning you
just feel like you waking up you're not
refreshed that is one symptom even your
IQ but why because again remember the
iodine effect
the brain especially in a growing person
but also an adult too so not that you
will feel mentally [ __ ] but you
could feel a little mentally [ __ ]
psychiatric disorders mental retardation
also are a lot of them are iodine
deficiency and of course they just treat
them with drugs unfortunately they're
not looking at the nutrition why because
they're not taught nutrition in school
only 25% of the colleges universities
that teach medical doctors teach
nutrition and out of those about they'll
teach them 6 to 11 hours maybe 20 hours
so you'd be better off asking a neighbor
because they just don't have the
information on these key natural
remedies okay so we have that cancer can
also be as a symptom of an iodine
deficiency so if you want to go to a
great website and now post it down here
Jeffery Dodge it's da CH com I'll post
it down there and this medical doctor
basically found that you can put a lot
of breast cancer in remission by adding
iodine to the diet so I want you to read
that if you have worried about cancer
and that's very interesting cancer of
the breast cancer of the stomach and
other cancers ok fibrocystic breasts oh
my gosh there's a lot of research on
taking iodine for fibrocystic breast to
eliminate that problem why because the
breast needs iodine and without it it
forms little cysts especially if you're
when you're breastfeeding you
concentrate a lot of iodine and that's
why it's very important for a mother to
consume enough of that trace mineral
before she's pregnant and maybe even
during the pregnancies in a very small
amount so that baby gets enough iodine
because without it she's gonna crave all
sorts of weird things to try to get it
but she might not get it okay so Farber
cystic breast is a symptom of iodine
problem cysts on the ovaries or the
testicle prostate enlargement could be
an iodine deficiency the
Russian fatigue slow thyroid Gorder a
bulge of a thyroid right there enlarges
that could be a iodine deficiency a lot
of menstrual cycle issues polycystic
ovarian syndrome that would be those
there's people that have facial hair
acne they get gut wait and one of the
doctors who they put them on metformin
because they try to treat them for
insulin resistance but what about iodine
given some iodine see what happens
salivary saliva deficiency so your mouth
can get really dry or dry eyes because
the ducts the salivary glands or the
other glands don't produce the fluid so
things can dry out that could be a
iodine deficiency and then thyroid
nodules and then migraines and then
miscarriages or stillbirths all that can
be iodine deficiency interesting foods
that have high iodine would be
strawberries eggs yogurt and seek help
but check this out you would have to
consume because the soils are so bad
11 cups of strawberries to get your
daily amount of iodine so who's gonna do
that six eggs
I have four a day so I'll have to have
two more or two large cups of yogurt
every day to get your iodine no one does
that
so or you can do one eighth of a cup of
seek help but of course what I'm gonna
recommend is do it in the capsule I'm
gonna recommend you get some seek help
three to six capsules a day of about 500
to 600 milligram tablets now that
doesn't mean that it's 500 600
milligrams of iodine that just means
they're sea kelp so they have all the
trace minerals so it's a smaller amount
but what's really cool about sea kelp is
that it's from the sea you have the
selenium to convert the thyroid from t4
to t3 it's all planet base so in other
words it's not a direct rock or an
element that our body has a hard time
absorber absorbing our bodies absorb
plant base trace minerals and just
minerals in general we do not do well
with things that are not coming
from a plant source or another source so
we need the plant source that was seek
help and then also you don't to worry
about trying to take a steroid
supplement that like an high dosage
because a lot of times doctors use high
dosages of iodine because it doesn't
absorb because they don't do it in the
plant base if you do plant base you
don't need as much because the body can
absorb it and it breaks it down very
easily so it's not about a shotgun
approach it's about just providing it
for the body to start absorbing it over
time so that's the source that I
recommend for you so I hope this
increased your awareness and I will see
you in the next video